[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
das grundrezept für leckere und
hauchdünne krebs
ich habe aus meinem rezept
klassischerweise krebs mit nutella
gezaubert ihr könnt das natürlich auch
mit marmelade genießen einfach nur mit
puderzucker oder anderen süßigkeiten für
den grund tag benötigen wir 450
milliliter milch eine prise salz
außerdem 30 gramm zucker 4 180 gramm
mehl und 60 gramm geschmolzene butter
der tag geht auch sehr schnell und
einfach wir müssen lediglich alle
zutaten miteinander verrühren
dafür gebe ich zuallererst die eier das
salz und den zucker in meine schüssel
und verrühren das mit einem schneebesen
[Musik]
anschließend gebe ich die milch mit
hinzu und auch die flüssige butter
[Musik]
nachdem wir dann alles schön glatt
verrückt haben geben wir das mehl mit
hinzu
am besten funktioniert der teig wenn die
eier zimmertemperatur haben und die
milch sowie die butter lauwarm sind
falls aber das mehl sich nicht ganz mit
dem teig verbinden möchte dann nimmt
einfach euren pürierstab den schritt
lasse ich eigentlich nie aus selbst wenn
die zutaten lauwarm sind bilden sich
manchmal diese kleine klümpchen und die
sind dann nicht besonders schön das ding
kurieren wir das noch mal kurz für eine
minute
nachdem das skript weisen nun dünn mit
back trends bei 1 gesprüht wurde ihr
könnt optional auch einfach öl verwenden
gebe ich eine kelle oder ein land halb
je nachdem wie dick ist mit vom teig auf
das skript eisen und verteile ist schön
[Musik]
was ihr hier nun im schnelldurchlauf
seht ist dass ich den teig zwei minuten
lang von jeder seite aus backe
[Musik]
ein paar sekunden bevor die zweite seite
aus gebacken wurde geben wir dann den
wunsch belag drauf
[Musik]
wer mag kann das dann auch noch
verstreichen und anschließend ist unser
erster klub auch schon fertig
[Musik]
übrigens erhaltet ihr aus dem teig
sieben große trips oder aber zehn
mittelgroße
[Musik]
und hier sehen wir wie einfach es
eigentlich ist krebs ohne großen aufwand
zu hause selber zu machen
und natürlich ist es auch viel günstiger
als wenn man sich krebs draußen kauft
am besten genießt ihr die krebs jetzt
noch schön warm ich habe noch
puderzucker darauf gegeben und mir das
ganze dann schmecken lassen
[Musik]
falls euch das rezept gefallen hat dann
lass mir doch gerne einen daumen hoch da
und bestenfalls noch ein abo damit ihr
auch keines meiner videos mehr verpasst
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]